back foot fadeaway throw just like
running around just off balance throwing
it footwork sloppy trying to make up for
it with the throw and he's not able to
do the same things that aaron rodgers
does so i think love just needs to focus
on developing his own style developing
his own way of playing the quarterback
position and not getting caught up so
much and trying to emulate aaron rodgers
because nobody can do that it's just
impossible to do there was a back foot
fadeaway right there
i don't i don't really think that he's
trying to emulate aaron rodgers what i
think he's trying to do he's just he's
getting reps so he's trying to get a
feel for it he's trying to figure out
the offense he's trying to figure out
the adjustments he's trying to figure
out what
personnel they have what rotation if
it's an eight-man box are they keeping
two guys back deep he's trying to figure
out all that pre-snap and then all of a
sudden he gets the snap then safeties
come and guys drop out so i think he's a
little confused jack and that's why you
see such terrible footwork now if aaron
rodgers is gone eventually they're gonna
take their time and they're gonna help
develop him and really work on his feet
as a quarterback yeah everybody focuses
on this but it's always about your feet
and if your feet are together and are
you under control and that's what tom
brady used to always tell me hey it's
all about your feet
i'm just thinking about the likelihood
and they do set up these plans right
they set up a plan for when brett favre
was towards the end of his career they
drafted aaron rodgers they brought him
in early they gave him time to sit to
learn and then he was ready when his
time came about four years down the line
so doing the same thing with love here
but it may just happen faster like i
just you know aaron rodgers do i think
he plays for the packers next year i
think it's unlikely at best it's
unlikely that he plays for the packers
next year so love is going to be this
guy and i i just thought after having a
year and a half of sitting behind rogers
and being in this office and being in
this building of learning of going
through the preseasons that this would
have looked prettier the first time out
and it looked pretty ugly the first time
out but i'm just thinking rod that is a
hard thing to do to try to go from far
to rogers to now love i think the
likelihood that they go three for three
here is about one in a billion i'll be
shocked
well i don't know about that i just
eric
the problem here is they haven't come
out and said that we're committed to
aaron rodgers now if you're committed to
aaron rodgers you need to agree to a
two-year extension a three-year
extension or whatever it might be but
i'm like you i believe that they're
gonna move on from aaron rodgers i don't
care how well he plays if even if he
wins a super bowl maybe if he wins the
super bowl they might think about
keeping them but for the most part i
mean but i do want to get shift to
something a little more positive what
about that defense devonta campbell
nobody's talking about devondre campbell
in addition to deandre campbell he's
playing like one of the top middle
linebackers in all of football he was
with atlanta falcons i got a chance to
see him here he was with the arizona
cardinals for a short period of time but
he's come in and he's really made a
difference on their team as well as
rashaan gary he's leading him in
sacks well while we're on the topic of
defensive football let's spin it to the
tennessee titans we were here in l.a
titans rams rams had looked so good all
year harold landry top three in the
entire league and pressure so we had
been seeing him start to come to the top
of this nfl in terms of pass rushers
talk to him right after that game about
the identity about what they're building
there with coach bravel i thought he had
a really interesting answer let's play
that back here was harold lancer right
after a big win
and guess what i think he's going to be
a free agent that probably gonna get
paid
look at him smiling
hey dawg we over here in your pockets
man what's going on how's it going buddy
it's going great how about you we're
doing okay how'd that one feel for you
guys oh it felt awesome like kb said it
best man we ain't out to prove anybody
wrong we're out to prove ourselves right
we know how good we are in that locker
room man we came out here played our
brand of football and we knew this was
what was what could happen here what was
the hero what was the game plan going in
because it seemed like you guys kept two
safeties deep you didn't want to give up
the big play and allow your front guys
to get after the quarterback yeah no we
knew coming into this game that you know
for for our defense to have success our
front was going to have to impact the
game at a high level
and you know when we came in and we were
able to do that give us a sense for
coach brabel coach bravel in the
attitude he instills in this team like
give us a sense how he actually gives
you guys that attitude
no i mean he just said it man like
no matter who we play no matter what
time where it's at man
he gives us a game plan we go out there
and execute it and like that's the
mantra that we have man it don't matter
what the situation is we're gonna
prepare our ass off and come out here
and play our brand of football and
that's what it's about
well rob we really didn't know who would
who would pick up right derek henry's
out for an extended period of time we
didn't know who would step in there and
shoulder some of this added
responsibility tana hill adrian peterson
it really wound up being this defense
how great were they it was awesome
spending time with landry after the game
too
yeah it was amazing when i watched them
and we end up you and i we both picked
the rams but i told you on the field i
said man there's something about
tennessee just the way they were warming
up the level of focus that they had and
just
how big the players were i mean i went
up to adrian peterson he was like 20
pounds bigger than me i'm like man you
look good but for the most part man it's
it's just about that defensive front we
asked you asked me you know what's the
biggest difference it's been jeffrey
simmons it's been harold landry the
third it's been denico altre jeffrey
simmons came in and he's probably the
best player that you've never really get
resp he never really gets any respect i
mean he's a he's a a player that can get
after the quarterback he stops to run
and he completely dominated on sunday
night and he really set the tone
nine pressures he had five hits three
sacks it was just a mega game for him
and he's somebody who fell in the first
round because of an off the field
situation but now he's playing like a
top five pick on that defensive front
and that's a scary thought with this
titans team and i you made the point
about how big of body guys they have i
think it's intentional just look at
their receivers look at julio a.j brown
derrick henry when he's back there their
offensive line i think they want size
they want physicality in the way that
they build this roster and they play
that way they play with the attitude of
their coach and coach rabel and we have
size and that kind of an attitude it's a
scary combination to try to go up
against and you're seeing this team now
come to life i mean they beat kansas
city handedly the bills handedly now
they come out to la they beat the rams
handily they're 6-0 against teams who
were in the playoffs last year so i just
think you have to start giving respect
to a team that's out there in the middle
of nowhere tennessee or whatever but
they are beating everybody the titans
are right back at the top of the afc
where they've been the last few years
and you know what bro just what you said
they beat all those teams and that's why
i think coach brabo should definitely be
mentioned in the coach of the year
conversation i mean just what he's been
able to do i mean you think about him
losing his best player um
luke and derrick henry going out west
and being able to blow out a team that
everybody thought or everybody think was
going to the super bowl that was going
to play the super bowl at home so to me
i just look at vrebel and you could tell
with harold landry he says whatever
coach tell us to do we're gonna do they
trust mike vrabel they trust him yeah
braver works extremely hard he's smart
um
he's kind of forming a defense like we
had really big big up front up um really
big guys up front guys that are very
versatile at the linebacker position and
the secondary that does a great job of
communicating and safeties that can make
plays on the ball and that's exactly
what they've got kevin buyer man we
like you can't i can't speak highly
enough about kevin bart and what he's
doing as far as
watching him cover guys wide receivers
tight ends coming up i mean this was
this was an all-pro play and you tell me
and he hasn't been mentioned in the
defensive player of the year
conversation this guy's flat out ball
and look at him just reading the
quarterback and this is this is just
what he does since he's been in the
league he's been a top play making
safety in the national football league
and you know what vrabel you can't get
any better than kevin byer
he's really stepped up his game
i'm right there with he's been the best
safety in the league you just made that
point and by far in my opinion he's been
the best safety lead that's film study
when you think about him reading that
out route knowing right when they go to
it that's just an easy comfortable
completion for stafford not so much when
buyer knows what's coming but you think
about the pick six then also the other
interception that ended up putting the
ball right at the one yard line for the
easy payoff touchdown the defense was
creating scoring opportunities in this
game and they were able to pay them off
get to your third takeaway keep it on
the defensive side of the ball in new
england something's starting to form
there and jc jackson has been the
headliner
yeah man you know just think about this
your number one corner stephon gilmore a
guy that was the defensive player of the
year a couple years ago he gets hurt
and
belichick ends up trading him jc jackson
steps up he becomes the number one
cornerback he had nine interceptions
last year and everybody thought okay
maybe this is just a one-year phenom and
you know will he be able to come back
and show a level of consistency he came
back this year had two picks on sunday
had five total and he's been outstanding
and if i were the patriots i would have
went to j.c jackson this offseason and
said jc i'm going to offer you four year
40 million with 20 million dollars to
sign
and
now
he probably would have said well maybe
with that type of security that he had
but now it's going to cost somebody 15
to 17 million dollars a year to sign
this guy he is a number one corner he's
played extremely well he's not afraid to
come up and tackle and you know
unfortunately i don't think the
the patriots will invest this type of
money to try to keep this young man
i don't think they will either it's not
exactly their strategy not the way that
coach belichick likes to do business is
overpaying for players like that when
they they do pay somebody like judon you
expect some really serious results but
look at new england now they've won four
out of their last five i've always had
this theory rod and i want to question
you on this a little bit too
so through september through october
that belichick just gets experimental
he'll try new defenses he'll implement a
whole bunch of different schemes and
disguises try different personnel
different players at different spots and
by the time we get to november in
december
it starts to feel like they know who
they are they have an identity they
start playing their best football and
then they put together one of these
great patriot runs so inside the
building how does that actually work as
he sort of just starts turning all the
gears and getting everything right
through about september and october and
finally you see their best football
right about now
it just comes down to coaches coaching
coaches coach in the players play and
his he says hey our job is to get you
guys prepared your job is to come in
here and learn as much as you can
mentally prepare yourself physically and
be on that football field so you can
practice and pay attention in those
meetings so none of this is surprising
to me it's always been a process it's
nothing that you could just get in one
day it takes over the course of an
entire season to build trust to build
faith to understand that hey if i tell
one of my guys i'm gonna be there he can
look at me and know 100 then i'm going
to be there for him so it's it's
chemistry it's continuity it's trust
it's faith in one another it's all those
things but the patriots defense is
getting a lot better um there's a lot
more stout up front and they're playing
a lot better in the back end
and with how long this season is and
with having a rookie quarterback and mac
jones you got to think that they're just
going to continue as we hit december as
we hit january this is going to be a
team that is just going to keep on
getting better let's get to arizona the
cardinals playing without their best
this your fourth takeaway rod so they
had no kyle murray no deandre hopkins
obviously watt is out for a long period
of time the rest of the season so how
are they able to go keep winning and
beating san francisco
yeah i mean i got to give credit to
general manager steve kahn i mean for
building a deep talented roster with a
quarterback that's on his rookie deal so
now you can go out and you can get guys
like look at think about they went out
and got marcus golden who was there
before now he's the lead he's their
leading soccer and he had three sacks on
sunday i mean he's been playing
outstanding you look at
vance joseph defensive coordinator the
type of job that he's doing with isaiah
simmons and some of those other players
that are playing
i just think that this is this team they
believe in one another
the fact that they didn't have they
didn't have deandre hopkins they didn't
have kylie murray they didn't have some
of their main weapons but they still
believe that they can win i think this
is this is great for them because now
they're showing that they can win in
different ways and it's going to be
tough man to beat these guys byron
murphy jr he's playing quarterback he's
playing like an all-pro they got some
ballers on the defensive side of the
ball and they don't even have some of
their starters on the offensive side of
the ball it's crazy man
a whole bunch of their starters they're
playing without you think about colt
mccoy who steps into this offense and
he's a completely different style of
quarterback he's not somebody who's a a
running quarterback this isn't mike vick
back there in cole mccoy been in the
league 10 plus years and i thought this
was maybe the best game we've ever seen
colt mccoy play ever i don't i can't
remember a game yeah where i've seen
colt mccoy play like this and he did it
with james connor who comes in randell
moore who comes in christian kirk he
made look like a number one receiver and
then zach hurts made some nice plays too
so it's the second string guys like it
makes me think back rod to amari cooper
remember amari cooper the point he made
to us about dallas was depth has never
been more important with the eternity of
a season we're going into with the
marathon effect that this is you've got
to have depth and arizona prove that
they do
no doubt now look at running back james
connor he looks like he's rejuvenated
his career he looks like a totally
different back behind this offensive
line he's got 10 touchdowns and he's
playing i mean he's healthy and you can
see
the toughness you can see the size you
can see the speed all the things that we
couldn't necessarily see in pittsburgh
because they didn't have a great
offensive line you're really starting to
see it and you talk about christian kirk
a guy that's in the slot i mean he could
do it all as well and now he's showing
you that he can pass
he can throw the football so arizona man
i'll tell you man this is a highly
talented team you got to give a lot of
credit to cliff kingsbury and what he's
been able to do because most people
thought that last year that like what
the heck is this guys doing he doesn't
know what he's doing come to find out he
knows exactly what he's doing he loves
his talent and he's got plenty of it
jack
and when they get everybody back look
out when they get all those players back
deandre hopkins like i would take your
time let hopkins hamstring come back
make sure you get you know murray's full
athleticism back you have time now when
you can get these sort of off weeks if
you will these off weeks with all your
best players it's almost like they're
built in with this 18 game schedule you
know what i mean it's almost like you
have a little bit of this where you use
it as a ball i have to play
that's right that's exactly right if you
can use it as a buy though and still win
what a boost that is to be able to get
your guys healthy and get a win let's
get to your fifth takeaway rod which is
andy reid go ahead let me just say this
yep
with these injuries you also give those
younger guys an opportunity to get that
planned experience and not only do they
get planned experience they get planned
experience with the first team that's
what you want because who knows like we
talked about it's a 17 week season you
know as some of the older players might
be achy you need some of those young
guys that say you know what i played
earlier in the season so i can come
right in i got my confidence i've got
this experience i played with this guy
before we we know that we trust each
other communicate all those things play
a factor too
that's right and it's inevitable that at
least a handful of those guys are going
to have to come back at some point in
the season and play one of those
starting roles let's get to andy reid
still doesn't quite look like andy reid
like we're so used to seeing this like
globetrotter type offense where just
these amazing things are happening
you're blown away it's still not there
rod why what are you seeing from andy
reid even in a win
well andy reed has to be better you know
i mean he has to coach better and when i
say that i mean he has to recognize that
his quarterback he's not playing with a
lot of confidence and
as a professional football player we we
all struggle with confidence i don't
care i'm tom brady he struggles with
confidence no matter what what we
accomplish no matter what we accomplish
no matter what we've done in our career
at times we struggle with confidence if
you're andy reid and you see that then
run the football if everybody's keeping
two safeties deep run the football andy
reed you've done it before i've seen you
in philly i've seen you with kansas city
run the football but the problem is this
a lot of times those offensive
coordinators they want to put up numbers
they want numbers they want four
thousand five thousand passing yards
they want thirty plus touchdowns they
want six interception or eight
interceptions unless they want to put up
numbers if they can't put up numbers
then they feel like they're not being
productive but last time i checked jack
i thought the name of the game was to
win win a football game so if i'm andy
reid i'm taking the ball out of patrick
mahomes hands a little bit more i'm
running a football and eventually i'm
going to force them to use one of those
safeties which is going to open up the
deep part of the field
yeah there you go and that's that would
be the plan i think they want clyde
edwards elaire back to help that cause
of going more so in on that running game
and they're just not pushing the ball
down the field i mean look you look at
patrick mahomes his yards per attempt
it's come way way down as we look i look
at it right now 4.5 is what he's at so
it just keeps coming down further
further as this this new playbook is out
in terms of how to defend them and if
you look at this game you go back and
watch this game
twice kansas city went for it on fourth
and one in their own territory i got
their own 35 40 yard line at the
beginning this game one time they got it
one time they gave the ball right back
so they're still trying to play overly
aggressive it's just not working in the
same way that it did not say the other
area you noticed is that you get down
around the red area andy reads
creativity where this game gets so
complicated his creativity just used to
be able to create seven and he would
have guys running wide open with all
these crossing routes and stuff and you
just don't see that anymore they get
down around the red area and they're
getting stuffed and mahomes doesn't know
what to do when he's getting hit and
nobody's open so that's really where
they're frustrating him is the red area
and the inability to go deep
well he also
exactly he also that's exactly what he
talked about he says well i struggle
with them keeping two safeties back i
have to learn to be patient and check
the ball down so
this is very frustrating to patrick
mahomes because he's a guy he's used to
running around throwing passes throwing
the ball down the field and guys running
underneath it but he's not able to do
that anymore and that's where the
frustration lies so now we have to see
can he make the necessary adjustment to
become a better quarterback not for
yourself but for your team and start
being a lot more patient
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports